the Disney verse is ripe with brave and
inspiring princesses who never fail to
stay true to who they are these
princesses all come from different
backgrounds and they vary in age we're
about to dive into the Disney verse and
reveal our hero's real ages and origins
you won't believe how much things have
changed since the first Disney Princess
was introduced to the world all the
thingamabobs in this entire world I
never thought I'd get to where unreal
what's it called again Snow White
once upon a time there was a young and
beautiful princess named Snow White her
story is still one of the most popular
fairy tales in the world today but did
you know that it's actually believed
that Snow White was a real person who
lived in Germany throughout the Middle
Ages the world first heard about the
fourteen-year-old princess when the
grimm brothers wrote and published a
collection of tales in 1812 Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs became a widely
popular tale that was passed down from
generation to generation
however in 1937 Walt Disney animated
Snow White's story which turned her into
a worldwide phenomenon since the young
princess story revolves around wicked
witches kingdoms and dwarves many people
believe her tale to be fictional however
there's a lot of evidence disproving
this theory in fact Snow White might
have actually been a living and
breathing person who was married when
she was only 14 years old this simply
would not fly in today's day and age but
once upon a time getting married at such
a young age was perfectly normal
Cinderella much like Snow White
Cinderella is one of the most well known
Disney Princesses in the world and
that's probably because she was the
second princess to be showcased in the
Disney lineup Cinderella's story comes
in many different versions the most
popular one being charles perrault's
fairy tale sin drillin which was
published in 1697
this is the story Disney originally drew
inspiration from puros story told to
tell of a 19 year old woman who lived
somewhere in France with her widowed
father unfortunately he soon remarried
with hopes of giving his daughter the
family she deserved but after his sudden
passing Cinderella was forced into
servitude and solitude leaving her to
converse with the mice and birds her
life changed for the better when her
fairy godmother paid her a visit and
helped her win a Prince's heart
Walt Disney Animation's
Studios turned Cinderella's story into
an animated classic in 1950 transforming
her into a timeless legend I'd flora
fauna Merryweather Sleeping Beauty
Disney fans know and love Aurora who is
known for being the protagonist and
Sleeping Beauty
Aurora's story takes place in France
however there are so many ancient
adoptions of her story that it's hard to
know for sure where it originated the
young princess was cursed to sleep for
100 years on the eve of her 16th
birthday however she was later awakened
by true love's kiss which has proven
itself to be the strongest weapon in the
Disney verse the earliest version of
Sleeping Beauty was written in the 14th
century however it was revamped in 1634
and published by gyeom Bautista by Co
famous French writer Charles Perrault
spun this fairy tale once more in 1697
giving it the classic storyline we all
know and love
Perrault's version was collected and
printed by the Brothers Grimm and later
animated by Walt Disney in 1959 so it's
safe to say that princess Aurora's story
has been lost in translation
still some believe that she once roamed
the earth under very different
circumstances
Ariel Once Upon a Time in the Baltic Sea
there was an underground mermaid Kingdom
which was ruled by the respectable King
Triton the widowed King had seven
daughters the youngest and the most
fierce one being 16 year old Ariel
princess Ariel's fairy tale was written
by Danish author Hans Christian Andersen
which was first published in Copenhagen
Denmark in 1837
although Ariel's story has changed
tremendously over the years one thing
remains the same area was willing to do
anything to shed her mermaid fins and
gain a human soul Andersen chose to take
a very tragic story and give it a happy
ending which totally caught Disney's
attention Walt Disney Animation Studios
rewrote Andersen story and published an
animated film with the same name in 1989
although Snow White and Cinderella might
be the most well-known fairy tales in
the world Ariel is by far one of the
most beloved Disney Princesses ever did
you guys know that there's a statue of
the original Ariel in Copenhagen Denmark
it's definitely something to check out
if you ever travel to that part of the
world and you'll win first prize at the
fair
tomorrow and become a world-famous
inventor Belle Princess Belle is an
intelligent and brave seventeen year old
woman whose towel is literally as old as
time
it's believed that her story was written
in the second century in fact some
fanatics believe Beauty and the Beast to
be the first fairy tale ever created
however the first draft of this story
was published by Gabrielle Susan de vil
louvet in 1740 the world as we know it
believes that Belle's origins are rooted
in France much like Cinderella and
Aurora's Gabrielle Suzanne's original
work was over a hundred pages long and
told a very different tale than the one
were familiar with in 1757 author Marie
lip prints de Beaumont shortens and
revamped gabrielle Suzanne's story
making it more child-friendly and over
two centuries later Disney chose to
animate Belle's fairy tale and turn it
into the masterpiece it is today
although we might have met Disney's
Belle in 1991 her story has allegedly
been around for thousands of years
Pocahontas many of us know Pocahontas as
the eighteen-year-old Disney Princess
who chose to listen to her heart instead
of her head the world first met her in
1995 when the Disney classic Pocahontas
was initially released however
Pocahontas story is far from being a
fairy tale in fact Pocahontas was a
real-life person who lived in what would
become Jamestown Virginia in 1595 much
like her story depicts Pocahontas was
the daughter of Chief Powhatan a mighty
leader who ruled over more than 30
Algonquin communities however it said
that Pocahontas was only 10 years old
when her story began which is a lot
younger than we were led to believe
Disney's Pocahontas might have lived her
version of a happily ever after but the
real Pocahontas story turned sour very
quickly still after so many centuries
her spirited memories always right
around the Riverbend Tiana
nineteen-year-old Tiana from Disney's
princess in the frog was a hard-working
waitress who dreamed of opening her own
restaurant
in New Orleans her story takes place in
the 1920s and was written and developed
by Ron Clements and John Musker however
Tiana's story was inspired by two
different fables which combine to form
the old
Disney Princess Tiana made her grand
debut in 2009 but her story is a lot
older than that Tiana's backstory was
loosely based off of Edie Baker's the
Frog princess who originally went by the
name princess Emma this novel was
created in 2002 and quickly gained a
following Princess Tiana was also
inspired by the Roman fairy tale the
Frog King Disney used both these stories
as inspiration while creating the first
ever african-american Disney Princess
Rapunzel in 2010 Disney released the
beloved animated film tingled and it
quickly became one of the world's most
favorite stories eighteen-year-old
Rapunzel was kidnapped at birth and
forced to spend her life in a tower
however she managed to escape and
vanquish her captor
mother Gothel there are so many versions
of Rapunzel's story that it's hard to
keep track of them although the Brothers
Grimm published Rapunzel's dreary tale
in 1812 it said that Jacobus de veau
regain Archbishop of Genoa first wrote
about Rapunzel's story in 1275 C II the
first version referred to Rapunzel as a
saint and not a princess in fact her
real name is believed to be Saint
Barbara this woman was allegedly in
prisons in a tower by her father for
refusing to marry and casting away her
Roman beliefs to partake in Christianity
all in all every version of Rapunzel's
story places her in a tower but little
else is known about her origins Merida
unlike most Disney Princesses Merida's
story isn't based on actual events
instead it was purely created by writer
and director Brenda Chapman who drew
inspiration from her and her daughter's
relationship Disney released brave in
2012 and totally broke the mold with the
new age royal instead of falling in love
and marrying a prince at the end of her
story meredith chose to be herself and
follow her dreams not her hearts brave
takes place in 10th century Scotland
however Merida hails from the kingdom of
dunbroch the 16 year old fiery princess
fights to be herself despite her parents
wanting her to get married here's a fun
fact for you there haven't been bears in
Scotland since the 10th century which is
probably why Disney chose to base their
story in this era narrative story is new
and inspiring although it does draw
inspiration from Hans Christian
Anderson and the Brothers Grimm many
fairy tales Anna and Elsa in 2012 Disney
released what would become their most
successful animated movie ever frozen
the story of princess Elsa and Anna was
inspired by Hans Christian Andersen's
The Snow Queen Anna was modeled after
the character Gerda
however Anna was 18 years old in her
film whereas Gerda was just a young
child and Hans original story Gerda
wandered aimlessly to find her childhood
friends hi who had been infected and
enthralled by The Snow Queen Disney
chose to combine Kai in The Snow Queen
to create Elsa who eventually became
Ana's 21 year old sister frozen may take
place in the magical land that is
arendelle but it said that their story
truly takes place in Norway Moana in
2016 Disney released its animated
masterpiece Moana which quickly became
the talk of the town Moana is the
sixteen-year-old daughter of the chief
of months Nui and she's expected to take
care of her people in her father's stead
Disney created this epic film by
combining a series of stories and
mythology z' and his magical fish hook
and the heart of PT were lost originally
Moana was supposed to be about Maui's
backstory however with so much content
to choose from Disney creators revamps
Maui's backstory and integrated it with
a fictional character in Mona's timeline
mallanna's story takes place over 3,000
years ago in the islands of Polynesia
and much like Merida Moana wasn't forced
to get married at the end of her story
turns out 16 years old is a little too
young to tie the knot a lot has changed
since no white story was animated by
Disney in 1937 and we're happy to hear
it
so which Disney princess is your
favorite and why let us know in the
comment section and that's a wrap we
hope you liked our Disney Princess video
before you go give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time
[Music]